ministerial code in this country is very
much
central to upholding standards in public
life the prime minister is expected to
adhere to it and enforce it and yet at
this moment on the week the sugree
report was released and the behavior of
those at the heart of government has
very much been called into question it's
been watered down now the changes will
mean that breaking the ministerial code
will no longer be considered an
automatic resigning matter and that
minor breaches can be dealt with in
different ways via a reduction in salary
or an apology for example and in
practice that is often
how the code has been uh applied the
problem for the prime minister is that
he is about to be investigated by the
privileges committee who will look into
whether he misled parliament
over the downing street parties now
these changes will not directly affect
that but unsurprisingly opposition mps
have jumped on this today and said that
this is him
changing the rules ahead of that inquiry
trying to get himself
off the hook the slightly broader
problem will be the perception of this
by the public but also
by his own mps many of whom are still
very unhappy about what came out in the
sugray report and are still deciding on
how they're going to react and we've
heard this week
some of those mps coming out publicly
and saying that they no longer have
confidence in him and that it's time for
him to go it would take 54 letters of no
confidence to trigger a vote of no
confidence in the prime minister and
there will undoubtedly be concerned in
downing street that if this drip drip of
letters continues that the prime
minister could very soon find himself in
real trouble